[Música]
coisas comuns acontecem o tempo todo
coisa sim voluntárias estão acontecendo
sem que a gente perceba como por exemplo
a nossa respiração
talvez vocês não estejam percebendo mais
vocês estão respirando e por isso eu
convido vocês a prestarem atenção na sua
respiração
isso mesmo preste atenção no ar que
entra e no ar que sai pelas suas narinas
aceite o convite é isso mesmo que eu
peço perceba
neste momento o ar que entra eo ar que
sai pelas suas narinas percebeu o
momento exato em que o ar entra eo
momento exato em que o assai perceba que
quem aceitou este convite a sua coluna
se alinhou um pouco mais os seus olhos
se atentaram mais a mim e eu apenas
solicitei que vocês prestassem atenção
na respiração
a nossa respiração mesmo acontecendo de
forma involuntária em perspectivas
diferentes nós podemos torná la
consciente e podemos fazer com que o
ritmo da nossa respiração influencie nos
nossos estados físicos mentais e
emocionais
assim como esses estados físicos mentais
e emocionais
eles influenciam na nossa respiração
você deve ter percebido como ficou a sua
respiração quando você estava correndo
ou buscou realizar qualquer exercício
físico sistematizado
ou você deve ter percebido ou ter
sentido já aquela sensação do coração
saiu pela boca a boca seca
tudo isso por conta de estresse
ansiedade ou você deve ter percebido
como ficou a sua respiração quando em
dado momento você buscou passar a linha
no buraco de uma agulha
por isso eu te pergunto como você
respira
nesse sentido eu convido você a observar
um pouco mais a sua respiração perceber
todo o processo respiratório
a nossa respiração ela nos conecta com
ela nos resgata para o agora esse é o
momento mais importante das nossas vidas
e por que que eu agora é o momento mais
importante das nossas vidas porque esse
momento ele é tão precioso
muitas vezes nós estamos no presente
mais conectados com o nosso passado com
frustrações por conta às vezes da forma
como a pessoa falou com a gente ou pela
simples forma como a pessoa ligou pra
gente
muitas vezes nós estamos no presente
mais conectados com o nosso futuro
criando expectativas criando medos
criando pré ocupações nos preocupando
com antecedência com coisas que nem
aconteceram e coisas que a gente nem
sabe se vai acontecer e mesmo que isso
tudo aconteça somente a gente se
mantendo no agora no momento presente é
que nós saberemos exatamente como lidar
com essa situação
somente no mês mantendo no momento
presente no agora é que nós poderemos
proporcionar que o nosso cérebro ele
criação necessária pra gente lidar com
essa situação sem criar pares de opostos
sem criar pegos ou a versões
isso não quer dizer que a gente está
ignorando o nosso passado o nosso futuro
nem ontem nem amanhã
nós estamos apenas não vivendo no ontem
no amanhã
nós estamos estabelecendo um contato com
agora e quando a gente estabelece esse
contato com agora nós colhemos uma
compreensão maior sobre o que se passa
uma aceitação sobre o momento isso quais
trazer para nós um alívio do sofrimento
isso faz uma alegria brotar em nós
quando nós mantemos a nossa atenção no
presente no agora nós podemos conhecer
os nossos pensamentos e ainda dominar a
nossa mente a nossa mente é muito
sabotador e muitas vezes ela está nos
dominando quando a gente estabelece esse
contato com agora nós vamos nos livrando
da força do hábito
do automatismo mas para isso é
necessário um grande treinamento um
treinamento de atenção plena e técnicas
de respiração ações elas são eficientes
para nos mostrar que é no agora que a
nossa vida acontece quando nós
respiramos com consciência nós
influenciamos a modulação do nosso
sistema nervoso autônomo sistema nervoso
autônomo é aquele da regulação do
estresse na modulação autônoma nós temos
o ramo simpático e o ramo para simpático
um ramo simpático é o ramo da luta em
fuga
funciona mais ou menos assim com o
aumento da excitação cardíaca o aumento
da freqüência respiratória o sangue da
periferia do nosso corpo ele vem para o
centro e isso mobiliza os nossos órgãos
mobiliza os nossos músculos para
realizar a ação necessária naquele
momento numa situação de stress agudo é
bem importante que o ramo simpático ele
esteja agindo porque assim nós vamos
saber exatamente o que fazer naquele
momento mas quando passa toda essa
situação de luta e fugas situação de
stress o rumo para simpático começa a
agir que é o ramo da calma tranquilidade
do equilíbrio do relaxamento então
acontece uma diminuição dos batimentos
cardíacos a nossa freqüência
respiratória é diminuída e restabelecida
obviamente isso vai influenciar no
relaxamento dos nossos músculos ou seja
o roubo para simpático é o freio para o
ramo simpático
só que o que acontece é que muitas vezes
essa nessa luta e fuga esse estresse ele
ainda continua nos nossos pensamentos na
nossa mente e isso causa uma
hiperativação simpática prolongada e
isso são fatores para o desenvolvimento
de stress crónico ansiedade fobias medos
internos insegurança depressão
dificuldade de relacionamento social
dentre todos os fatores negativos que o
estresse traz pra gente nosso poder
ainda destacar o aumento da dor crônica
e problemas gastrointestinais ou seja
nós podemos influenciar a modulação
autônoma através do controle da nossa
respiração mas para isso ser bem
eficiente essa respiração ela deve
acontecer ritmada uma respiração em
determinado ritmo ela atinge o nervo
vago para simpático mas essa respiração
não pode acontecer de qualquer forma ela
tem que ser nasal diafragmática com a
movimentação do músculo diafragma
abdominal com a exalação maior do que
uma inalação e porque a respiração ela
deve ser nasal
quando nós respiramos pelo nariz nós
filtramos e aquecemos o ar que entra uma
vez que o ar frio ele é prejudicial para
o nosso sistema respiratório e quando
nós exalamos o dobro do tempo
nós atingimos com mais agilidade o nervo
vago para simpático e nós vamos
obviamente sentindo essa calma essa
tranquilidade esse relaxamento mais
rápido a ciência hoje disse que se nós
respirarmos nasal pelo nariz abdominal
com músculo a movimentação do músculo
diafragma com a instalação maior do que
a inalação
nós podemos produzir o que a ciência
hoje chama de coerência cardíaca ou
freqüência de ressonância
cardiorrespiratória e o que vem a ser
essa coerência cardíaca é quando nós
sincronizamos a nossa respiração com as
batidas do nosso coração trazendo as
seis respirações por minuto ou menos
hoje em dia nós respiramos de 9 a 24
respirações por minuto ou seja a nossa
respiração ela é curta é acelerada pra
gente ainda lidar com todas as situações
desafiadoras da nossa vida
então o treino dessa respiração nasal
abdominal diafragmática com a instalação
maior do que a inalação ela influencia
nesse ritmo de 6 respirações por minuto
aumentando a ação do nervo vago para
simpático o que provoca em nós uma
redução inclusive das emoções negativas
só que pra gente atingir essas
respirações por minuto
nós devemos inalar num tempo e exalar o
dobro do tempo como por exemplo inalar
contando o tempo de 3 e exalar contando
o tempo de 6
parece fácil né é na verdade é o desafio
mesmo a gente encontrar um tempo
necessário pra gente treinar essa
respiração para que o nosso cérebro ele
treine essa respiração e compreenda o
processo respiratório
os pesquisadores hoje dizem que se nós
treinamos essa respiração um pouco todos
os dias como um freio para hiperativação
do estresse o restabelecimento
fisiológico
nós vamos fazer com que o nosso
organismo ele encontra as ferramentas
necessárias para que o nosso corpo saiba
é como agir numa situação desafiadora
é claro que nós não vamos treinar essa
respiração 24 horas por dia
nós vamos treinar um pouco todos os dias
em dado momento a ciência diz que nós
teremos criado então um novo padrão
mental e fisiológico a ciência diz que
nós treinamos essa respiração nós
estaremos reduzindo estado de depressão
e de ansiedade transformando a nossa
mente fazendo com que a gente saiba
lidar melhor com os nossos pensamentos
sentimentos e emoções tudo isso inalando
no tempo e exalando o dobro do tempo e
na holanda em 3 e exalando em seis
tempos eu conheci mais sobre essa
respiração através do yoga eu sou
formado em educação física e tive
experiências diversas no ramo
todas as experiências que eu tive
colaboraram para ser a instrutora de
yoga que eu sou hoje que ao contrário do
que muitas pessoas pensam não se trata
de uma religião e sim uma filosofia de
vida com o objetivo principal de nos
levarmos nos conduzimos ao caminho da
autorrealização essa respiração que eu
acabo de falar pra vocês nas áudio
fragma ática com a instalação maior do
que a inalação no yoga chamada de
respiração coronária as respirações no
yoga chamadas são chamas
as de praia mas prana quer dizer energia
vital
aí ama quer dizer cumprimento quer dizer
extensão do plano controle do paraná
quando realizam praia então tente
controlar essa extensão do plano da
energia vital em mim
as inspirações no yoga elas nos trazem
para o agora para o momento presente
os grandes mestres dizem que a nossa
mente é controlada quando a nossa
respiração é controlada dentro do yoga
sua respiração as respirações elas têm o
objetivo de fazer com que a gente
alcance a transformação da nossa mente
para transcender a nossa consciência
existe um grande sábio no yoga chamado
patânjali patânjali foi quem cuide ficou
o yoga e patógenos direciono oito
hangares que são oito passos que nos
conduzem esse grande método de
auto-realização ea respiração é o quarto
passo desse grande método ou seja a
respiração ela é a grande chave dentro
do yoga pra gente dominar os nossos
sentidos a nossa mente os processos
mentais e ainda encontrar o caminho da
autorrealização a respiração ela nos
leva a um estado de olga que a tradução
da palavra união união de nós com nós
mesmos
um outro grande sábio no yoga nos disse
que o nosso tempo de vida é contado pelo
número de respirações que a gente dá são
2600 respirações por dia ou seja se eu
respiro calmo prolongado mais plana mas
energia vital mais vida
agora se eu respiro rápido a curto
acelerado estou desperdiçando energia
vital ou seja estou morrendo mais rápido
e fácil de entender isso né
incrivelmente assim como no yoga a nossa
respiração essa grande chave que nos
conecta com agora com o momento presente
transcendendo a esse estado de
consciência a ciência hoje já comprova
que a nossa respiração ela produza um
aumento da nossa atenção e do
relaxamento a ciência hoje comprova que
a nossa respiração é favorável ao
gerenciamento do nosso estado
s dos estados mentais porque influencia
na nossa modulação autônoma a ciência
hoje diz que a nossa respiração ela
favorece cada indivíduo a saber lidar
positivamente com as situações
desafiadoras do dia a dia como doenças
crônicas ansiedade stress depressão e se
a pessoa encontra nesse estado a
técnicas de respiração e também
colaboram para que a pessoa compreenda
aí consiga lidar melhor com esse desafio
a ciência disse que o treino de perceber
e dominar a nossa respiração transforma
a nossa mente
portanto eu convido vocês a experienciar
esse momento eu convido você a sentar
bem na pontinha da sua cadeira
alinhando bem a sua coluna aceite esse
convite
senti bem na pontinha da sua cadeira
linha sua coluna deixa suas mãos
repousar em cima das suas pernas do seu
material fecha seus olhos não
necessariamente você precisa adotar essa
postura
para realizar a técnica de respiração é
só um convite para te trazer mais pro
agora fecha seus olhos e na li contando
um tempo e exale contando o dobro desse
tempo sugestão e na li em 3 e exalem 6 e
na li contando 1123 exale 123456
prossiga dessa forma 123 exale 123456
continue a respirar com consciência
perceba o ar que entra no momento exato
em que ele entra pelas suas narinas e
percebo o ar que sai no momento exato em
que ele sai
se esse número não ficou confortável pra
você você pode reduzir inalando em dois
exilados em 4
mas se você sentiu que esse número foi
confortável você pode experience a
aumentar inalando em 4 e exalando em
oito tempos
encontre o número mais confortável pra
você
consciente de que agora você está
ativando a ação do nervo vago para
simpático que você ensina
nesse momento o seu corpo a lidar muito
melhor com as situações desafiadoras que
você agora se conecta com o momento
presente
mantenha sua respiração consciente
da próxima vez que você estiver exalando
ar o dobro do tempo você pode
interromper essa respiração coronária
voltando a ficar de forma confortável
como você sentir que é melhor pra você
que possamos utilizar essa técnica esse
recurso ao nosso favor
buscando a transformação positiva da
nossa mente equilibrando o nosso sistema
nervoso
lembrando que nós não estamos ignorando
a ação do nervo vago simpático porque é
bem importante a gente tem ação na nossa
vida nós estamos falando apenas pra
gente não manter esta hiperativação
simpática prolongada por conta dos
nossos processos mentais que nós
possamos viver de forma consciente o
momento presente entrando em contato com
o agora esse é o momento mais importante
das nossas vidas respiremos namastê
gratidão
[Aplausos]